sanitization point at the end of the
question show doesn't know how to
punctuate correctly though I admit the
retro ghoul chic style of this home is
appealing the steep incline in the
walkway and limited access by boat makes
it completely impractical three out of
ten
would not die easily reading a newspaper
and a thunderstorm on a speeding topless
motorboat that's right I said topless
motorboat newspapers position is lively
the worst news position of them all
because it involves reading aloud also
known as narrating Scooby's forehead
you're navigating some choppy stormy
waters right now maybe you could focus
on the driving instead of man tore up
dang Velma who was reading it just fine
thank you very much shaggy whines about
going on a scary adventure even though
we've seen no one force you to be there
you big baby cliche also how are they
even still in the water in the first
shot they were literally about to be on
the island creeps and crawls for this
job I have heard the Law Offices of
torture and porn are pretty reliable but
they forced you to take the time bear
trap head test before accepting it was a
client so creeps and crawls is a fine
backup choice scooby-doo where are you
clearly attended the marvel comic school
for character names also even from the
grave Colonel Sanders manages to
identify his heirs and the older they
are seated dogs don't talk also did I
have detect a laugh track in there in an
animated show I totally forget
hanna-barbera did that but they most
definitely did that and that's some
sinful sinful this fishbowl is
completely empty even though there is
obviously a fish in it a few seconds
later I get him animating was hard in
the 60s but if you're not going to
animate the fish just choose a shot that
the fish isn't in in the first place cuz
this just makes you look lazy
considering Scooby doesn't wear clothes
while the gang is out and about what's
the point of the bathrobe is scooby
brushing his teeth with soap I mean I
don't bathe or brush my teeth often but
I'm pretty sure that's not how it's done
but since he's running on all fours
straight into a wall why does the
outline look like he's standing up also
this is more a yogi bear shaped hole
than a Scooby shaped hole and believe me
I know my animated holes wait also also
good thing there just happened to be
stairs beyond the wall that scoob's
barreled into because he's already
pretty much guaranteed himself some
future CTE anyway except when it slid
back in it was still completely full of
water so what gives Fred must have a
second career as a quick-change artist
because just a few seconds ago he was
already in pyjamas but now he has his
shirt and scarf back on no worries
though he'll change back into pyjamas to
go inspect the tub you sure got some
imagination Strait much this music is
more distracting than Velma's thigh-high
socks get a load of this riding on this
dusty mirror smear reading and where did
all this come from anyways this house
doesn't look like it's even been lived
in for ages but I guess it had a stuck
MacGyver closet for all your last-minute
construction needs they survived this
also did the lake freeze over why is the
pipe they miraculously wrote down here
bouncing off and sitting on top of the
water the gang eventually pairs off into
a group of shaggy Scooby Velma and a
group of Fred and Daphne cliche
[Music]
you mean the footprints they were too
lazy to draw those footprints I count at
least five Confederate flags here so for
all of Velma's mystery solving skills
she doesn't exercise much caution I'm
not sure how her curiosity hasn't killed
her by now pretty obvious development is
at least a bit curious close enough
wrong commercials
[Music]
where the [ __ ] was the Phantom just then
where none of them could see it fred was
just been there I'm pretty sure when
you're feeding your organ you should be
watching the door not the floor but if
you had no clue how to play the piano or
read music I guess he would waste away
and die in this room sounds fair shaped
is it though personally I'm going to go
with academy-award shape but you do you
shag man every Scooby episode is legally
required to contain at least 20% running
and chasing haven't seen animation so
needlessly recycled since well every
Disney remake ever
yeah because how would you even get up
there the only way Scooby and Shaggy are
getting up there is that they can walk
on walls or fly and if they have those
kinds of abilities why would they be
scared of anything don't fire till you
see the green of his eyes his eyes are
rich why would releasing one cork
release every single other cork as well
don't like their dominoes dominoes
what the hell even is this joke so shag
and do found an impossible stretched
bicycle built for four somewhere inside
a house and got on it to ride and
somehow the ghosts also gone on at the
same time but they didn't notice until
halfway down the hall
this is aggressively surreal and if I
wanted spongebob I'd have just put in
spongebob this works with those green
ghosts how else I mean there would be a
million guesses that would come to mind
before ghosts dancing right
and the fan is so strong it's going to
suck a full ass washing machine and
ironing board into it that will then
magically form a plane that not only
flies but can carry the additional
weight of its giant passengers which is
nonsense because we all know you would
actually need a surfboard agree at that
kind of lip the hell you can't steer it
how are you gonna direct it to the
shortcut then they put dummies that look
just like them in the coffins but that
plan backfired backfired how did that
backfire
I mean you eventually caught them but it
wasn't because of anything that had to
do with the dummies right also not
explained is how the two managed to fly
or appear transparent well we're going
creeps and crawls could use a good
lawyer for what scaring people creating
a haunted house I'm not exactly sure
what the charges are here this fade puts
creeps and crawls in the exact position
is Shaggy and Daphne and I accidentally
paused it just as it looks like crawls
has Daphne's body and I'm not ready for
the feelings I'm having right now here
it is it all belongs to you now Scooby 1
million dollars I know we're about to
get a twist where the money is all
Confederate but Scooby was all set to
yank that money without one thought of
the other heirs who were tricked into
leaving not cool Scoob not cool and all
haunted bone isn't defined on the urban
dictionary is when you accept a booty
call from someone who has previously
ghosted you and that is absolutely a sin
if you think I'm not gonna take a sin
off for one of the best animated theme
songs ever then you're wrong yeah I
didn't take one off for x-men so I guess
I could remove an extra one here for
that but I won't
Episode does not contain a Winchester
brother
and what will it mean for for the wider
region I think one of your children's
just walked in make sure you click that
bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it his
only instructions were to play this
record for you I harlan thrombi i will
return to the island in the morning to
find out which of you is this haunted
room actually stretching
hey where are these stairs go they go up